[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie wieder dabei
sind wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sport treiben am tor von mir und das
sind unsere themen heute soforthilfe für
die opfer der hochwasserkatastrophe mit
zunächst 400 millionen euro sollen die
schlimmsten schäden beseitigt und
notlagen überbrückt werden mehr als nur
tränen trocknen viele flutopfer sind
schwer traumatisiert und benötigen
therapeutische hilfe und griechischer
superstar im basketball olymp mit einer
spektakulären vorstellung führt ja
nissan tito die milwaukee bucks zum us
meistertitel schnelle hilfe für die
flutopfer das hatte die politik in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder
versprochen
heute hat das kabinett den rahmen dafür
beschlossen und der innenminister sagt
dafür zahlen die leute steuern dass
ihnen in solchen situationen geholfen
wird die soforthilfe der bundesregierung
soll direkt an die betroffenen menschen
gehen 200 millionen euro sind dafür
vorgesehen
der bund verdoppelt damit die hilfe die
von den betroffenen ländern nordrhein
westfalen und rheinland pfalz geplant
wird insgesamt also 400 millionen nur
ein anfang denn der wiederaufbau der
infrastruktur wird milliarden
verschlingen klaus brodbeck die
luftwaffe über dem krisengebiet
ahrweiler rheinland pfalz heute
nachmittag tornados mit spezialkameras
sollen die von der flut betroffenen
gebiete kartieren
überall gilt je besser der überblick ist
er höher steigen die summen um die es
gehen wird die betroffenen länder und
der bund übernehmen die die hälfte eine
festgelegte grenze für die soforthilfe
gibt es nicht wenn es so ist dass mehr
gebraucht wird dann ist es so dass wir
auch mehr geld zur verfügung stellen
werden die länder
natürlich auch hier als und mit unseren
möglichkeiten
wir werden das tun was erforderlich ist
um jeden so schnell wie möglich zu elf
auf umständliche überprüfungen soll
verzichtet werden keine zeit für
komplizierte formulare dass dieses
unbürokratisch erfolgt das scheint mir
ganz wichtig dass da jetzt nicht große
einkommen solle oder vermögens
überprüfungen stattfinden sondern die
hilfe schnell stattfindet die grünen
warnen nothilfe allein wird in zukunft
nicht reichen
nothilfe ja das ist gut so und dann
kommt der wiederaufbau dann kommen
natürlich aber auch die frage welche
thema anpassungsmaßnahmen braucht man
ein neuer aufbruch soll helfen die
folgen der katastrophe zu beseitigen
wenigstens die materielle wir werden
neben mit der aufbauen werden geschäfte
wieder aufbauen wir werden fabriken
wieder aufbauen wir werden gebäude
wieder richten wir werden dafür sorgen
dass die unternehmen wieder loslegen
können dafür zahlen die leute ja steuern
dass ihnen auch in außergewöhnlichen
situationen geholfen wird
noch ist kein ende absehbar es geht um
milliarden und im jahr so viele menschen
in den vom hochwasser zerstörten orten
sind auf diese unterstützung dringend
angewiesen um das notwendigste fürs
tägliche leben zu beschaffen
und sie brauchen vermutlich noch viel
mehr hilfe wenn es darum geht wieder mit
dem eigenen beruf dem eigenen
unternehmen geld zu verdienen
stellvertretend schauen unsere
reporterinnen anja klingen und verena
david nach bernau im aartal
ursula die listen mit schwiegertochter
daniela schick bis vor einer woche war
das ihr heim und ihr eigenes kleines
taxiunternehmen
jetzt ist alles kaputt es ist mitten in
der nacht als das wasser die bewohner
überrascht ursula die listen ist zu dem
zeitpunkt nicht zu hause sein
da hat ja gar keiner mit gerechnet ich
habe glück gehabt dass ich auf der
autobahn war
der stuhl
sie ist mit dem taxi dienstlich
unterwegs der weg nach bernau vom wasser
versperrt die nacht verbringt sie daher
bei ihrer schwiegertochter erst am
nächsten morgen hört sie vom ausmaß des
unglücks
ich habe das am nächsten tag im
fernsehen gesehen und da war ich erst
mal ja fassungslos
das ganze haus ist voller schlamm möbel
und einrichtungsgegenstände können nur
noch entsorgt werden
vier von fünf taxis wurden mitgerissen
von der kraft des wassers nur das auto
in dem sie saß ist ihr geblieben 16
jahre selbstständigkeit einfach
weggespült wie es weitergehen soll
rücklagen hat sie nicht
es kann dazu es ist es im albtraum ich
habe jetzt noch ein taxi ich werde jetzt
hier in bernau das büro erstmal muss ich
ja kündigen
ja dafür auch entmutigt und erschöpft
die chance auf einen neuanfang kann es
für ursula gillessen nur geben mit
finanzieller hilfe von außen
maria geiger ist in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler in welcher verfassung
erlebst du die menschen
ja barbara die belastung für die
menschen hier die ist ungeheuer groß das
liegt zum einen daran dass sie
funktionieren müssen in der katastrophe
sie sind ja seit tagen dabei das sieht
man hier ganz gut ihre häuser und
wohnungen auszuräumen die ganzen trümmer
raus zu schaffen
und hier ist zwar schon viel passiert
aber dennoch ist auch noch ganz viel
händische arbeit nötig ich habe heute
gesehen wie leute den ganzen tag mit
schaufeln und eimern den schlamm aus dem
keller geholt haben
das ist eine sehr schwere arbeit des
strapaziöses ist hier inzwischen auch
staubig und heiß und die menschen sind
wirklich müde und erschöpft und all das
sind der verzweiflung so viel verloren
zu haben und der ungewissheit nicht zu
wissen wie es weiter geht und dann haben
sie noch diese schrecklichen geschichten
aus der flut nacht im kopf jeder hat
eine fürchterliche geschichte hier
erlebt und den menschen fehlt der
raumfeld die zeit sich zu besinnen und
darüber mal nachzudenken zu begreifen
was da passiert ist ein mann sagte mir
heute das sei nach wie vor wie im film
vielen dank für ihren geiger eine knappe
woche nach der katastrophe nacht steht
noch nicht fest wie viele menschen ihr
leben in den fluten verloren haben
bislang wurden 170 tote geborgen eine
vorläufige zahl die helfer rechnen damit
weitere opfer zu bergen
hoffnung noch überlebende zu finden
haben sie keine mehr
ganz wichtig ist es jetzt die menschen
in den unglücksgebieten auch psychisch
zu stützen
angela ebert und susanne gelhard
berichten
in kreuzberg bei altena sind die
notfallseelsorgerin seit tagen unterwegs
kamera orschler und dunja puschmann
kommen von der caritas und einer
katholischen gemeinde
der ort ist schwer zerstört die menschen
haben schreckliches erlebt es gibt
familien die haben ihre kinder verloren
oder kinder waren
auto eingesperrt ja dann
haben menschen gesehen wie leute einfach
im auto sagt man abgedriftet worden sind
genau menschen dann im haus eingesperrt
manche roten jetzt drei tagen erst
herausgeholt zu hören hilfe anbieten
organisieren das ist ihre wichtigste
aufgabe
es geht erstmal um stabilisierung ein
bisschen der normalität in dieser
unnormalen situation herzustellen
wenn die nacht hereinbricht wächst die
angst
vielerorts fehlen weiter wasser und
strom und doch bleiben viele aus sorge
vor plünderungen in ihren häusern
trotz polizeikontrollen man weiß nicht
mehr wohin wie lange es noch dauern wird
was noch alles passieren wird
die menschen sind schwer getroffen
gleich mehrfach in der einsatzzentrale
am nürburgring laufen die hilferufe ein
120 notfall kräfte aus ganz deutschland
stehen bereit
die leute sind in einem psychischen
ausnahmezustand
wir haben hier noch die besonderheit
dass das natürlich über tage geht jetzt
kommt so langsam auch eine psychische
erschöpfung es wird einfach bewusst was
da passiert ist doch immer wieder können
die seelsorgeteams helfen zum beispiel
in kreuzberg wo eine familie die mutter
vermisst gestern abend wurde sie in
einem krankenhaus gefunden ein
lichtblick in diesen schwierigen zeiten
die bereitschaft den menschen im
katastrophengebiet zu helfen es weiter
hoch bei der zdf spendenaktion sind
schon rund 20 millionen euro
zusammengekommen
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
ein spendenkonto eingerichtet die iban
laute de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8 190
trotz spenden und staatlicher hilfe am
besten versorgt sind die die sich gegen
überschwemmungen versichert haben mit
einer zusatzpolice gegen
elementarschäden die haben bundesweit
allerdings gerade mal 46 prozent der
privathäuser
verschiedene politiker fordern jetzt
eine solche elementarversicherung zur
pflicht zu machen
volker tucek hat mehr monika und josef
hubert leben in einem totalschaden in
ihrem haus im trierer stadtteil ehrang
riecht es überall nach heizöl und
brackwasser die beiden haben zwar eine
gebäude- und eine hausratversicherung
doch das reicht nicht
versicherung gebäudeversicherung
man hat alles verneint wir können ihnen
da nicht helfen da die
elementarversicherung müsste man mit
abgeschlossen aber nein gebäude und
beide haus haben die
elementarversicherung hätte die beiden
mehr als 1000 euro im jahr gekostet das
war ihnen damals zu viel geld zumal die
mosel wald weg ist eine
pflichtversicherung für jeden
immobilienbesitzer dafür spricht sich
baden württembergs ministerpräsident
schon länger aus ich glaube wenn man das
ausmaß der schäden sieht dass wir da
alle alle immobilienbesitzer müssen
praktisch in eine solidargemeinschaft
gehen sonst wird es erfolge haben wir
die bin nicht mehr gut bewältigen können
alle länder hand in hand ein schwieriges
projekt zumal es in nordrhein westfalen
und bayern schon gesetzt ist dass es
keine soforthilfe mehr gibt für schäden
die zu vernünftigen preisen versicherbar
sind
der versicherungsverband hält
pflichtversicherung für falsch dadurch
würden viele hausbesitzer keine eigenen
anstrengungen mehr zur flut absicherung
treffen nach dem motto die versicherung
wird mir schon helfen von der politik
brauchen wir ein gesamtkonzept nicht nur
für den katastrophenschutz sondern auch
für flächen planungen und für bau
planung die sich auch stellt den
herausforderungen des klimawandels
die verbraucherzentralen haben
rechtliche bedenken gegen die
pflichtversicherung
eine pflichtversicherung würde auf der
einen seite natürlich für eine
erhebliche erhöhung der
versicherungsdichte sorgen so dass im
wesentlichen alle häuser abgesichert
werden
auf der anderen seite ist natürlich eine
pflichtversicherung ein erheblicher
eingriff in grundrechte
und das muss gut begründet werden 50.000
euro kostet die renovierung haben monika
und josef hubert hochgerechnet die summe
müssen sie von 1200 euro rente im monat
abstottern
düstere perspektiven die bundesregierung
will künftig medizinische güter
einlagern um besser für notsituationen
gerüstet zu sein
in den nationale reserve sollen zunächst
mehr als eine milliarde maske gehen die
nach ansicht des rechnungshofs zu viel
eingekauft wurden später auch
schutzkleidung und bestimmte medikamente
außerdem will sich der bund künftige
impfstofflieferungen sichern
die reserve soll für ein halbes jahr
ausreichen zur corona infektions lage da
ist die sieben tage inzidenz weiter
leicht gestiegen auf nun 11 4
die gesundheitsämter haben dem
robert-koch-institut 2203 neue
infektionen binnen 24 stunden gemeldet
655 mehr als vergangenen mittwoch 19
todesfälle kamen hinzu aus angst vor
einer vierten welle gelten bei unserem
nachbarn frankreich ab heute wieder
schärfere regeln etwa beim pariser
eiffelturm aber auch in museen und kinos
mit mehr als 50 besuchern ist ein
gesundheitspass pflicht einheimische und
touristen müssen damit eine vollständige
impfung genesung oder einen negativ test
nachweisen
frankreich hat aktuell eine inzidenz von
tendenz steigend wer in der regierung
sitzt muss strikt trennen zwischen
staatsamt und partei theoretisch ist das
eine klare sache praktisch gar nicht so
einfach
etwa als angela merkel die
ministerpräsidenten wahl in thüringen
unverzeihlich nannte tat sie das als
kanzlerin oder als cdu politikerin für
die afg ist die sache klar
merkel habe damit im amt parteipolitik
betrieben
dagegen klagt die afg vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht christoph
schneider berichtet die wahl von thomas
kemmerich auch mit stimmen der afg zum
neuen ministerpräsidenten thüringens
löste bundesweit empörung aus einen tag
nach der wahl äußerte sich
bundeskanzlerin merkel bei einem
staatsempfang in südafrika
da dies absehbar war
in der kunst des konstellation wie im
dritten wahlgang gewählt wurde muss man
sagen dass dieser vorgang unverzeihlich
ist und deshalb auch das ergebnis wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden muss diese
äußerungen wurden so auch im internet
auf den seiten der kanzlerin und der
bundesregierung veröffentlicht dagegen
klagt die afg vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht sieht auch eine
verletzung der chancengleichheit der
parteien
ich denke schon dass die kanzlerin mit
diesen aussagen die sie ja in pretoria
getätigt hat uns klar als
antidemokratisch dargestellt das ist
nicht ginge eine demokratisch gewählte
ministerpräsident mit stimmen der afg
dass man das als antidemokratisch
dargestellt und das hat uns sehr wohl
geschadet
regierung und kanzleramt halten dagegen
merkel habe sich nicht in amtlicher
funktion geäußert sondern als
parteipolitikerin der cdu
allgemein gilt dass regierungsmitglieder
bei öffentlichen äußerungen
parteipolitisch neutral sein müssen
die bundesverfassungsrichterin ließen in
der mündlichen verhandlung bereits
durchblicken dass sie in der äußerung
von angela merkel ein angriff auf die
afg sehen da sie diese äußerungen bei
einem staatsbesuch und damit wohl in
dieser rolle als bundeskanzlerin die zur
neutralität verpflichtet ist getätigt
hat sind die erfolgsaussichten hier der
fc vor gericht zu gewinnen als hoch
einzuschätzen
das höchste deutsche gericht wird erst
in einigen monaten entscheiden
die umstrittene pipeline nord stream 2
soll gas von russland nach deutschland
bringen
zu den schärfsten kritikern des projekts
gehören seit jahren die usa jetzt aber
gibt es offenbar eine einigung mit
berlin
das bestätigte vor einer knappen stunde
ein sprecher der us regierung die fast
fertige pipeline verläuft von der
russischen ostseeküste bei sankt
petersburg durchs meer bis nach lubmin
bei greifswald vor allem die ukraine
befürchtet dass ihre position durch nord
stream zwei geschwächt werden könnte
denn bislang führen die meisten
gaspipelines von russland aus durch ihr
gebiet auch in china gibt es zurzeit
schwere überschwemmungen in der provinz
henan wo mindestens 25 menschen ums
leben gekommen sind vor allem in der
millionenstadt chongqing dort regnete es
an einem tag so viel wie sonst in acht
monaten zehntausende bewohner wurden in
sicherheit gebracht vielerorts gab es
keinen strom und trinkwasser aus der
überschwemmten u bahn wurden hunderte
eingeschlossenen gerettet
damit sind wir bei olympia und beim
thema corona fünf sportler sind positiv
getestet worden können an den
wettkämpfen nicht teilnehmen das gros
des britischen olympia teams das bleibt
wegen corona der eröffnungsfeier fern
die deutschen dagegen sind dabei so dsb
präsident hermann heute 95 prozent des
teams sein geimpft
auch das team deutschland hat den
olympischen orts und zeitwechsel gut
überstanden und die kritik am zum
jahresende ausscheidenden ezb-
präsidenten alfons hörmann vorerst ruhen
lassen
insofern bezeichne ich die spiele
weiterhin wie vor monaten nicht als
geisterspiele sondern wenn dann als
wertungsspiele die deutschen athleten
haben zeit die wettkampfstätten besser
kennenzulernen und zeigen sich wie
christian reitz mit der
schnellfeuerpistole voller vorfreude und
zuversicht wenn da vorkampf einigermaßen
gut läuft und da nicht irgendwie was
passiert wird es finale wohl keine hürde
sein und dann im finale als bestmögliche
rausholen
noch zweimal schlafen bis zur großen
eröffnungsfeier auch für das
ambitionierte team deutschland das sich
in japan in den kommenden gut zwei
wochen einen namen machen möchte mit
einer sportlichen überraschung und einer
politischen geste hat das olympische
frauenfußballturnier begonnen wie hier
vor der begegnung australien gegen
neuseeland knieten die spielerinnen als
zeichen gegen rassismus
diese partie endete 2 2 1 ja und die
weltmeisterin und megan rapinoe aus den
usa die kassierten nach 44 spielen ihre
allererste niederlage 1 0 zu 3 gegen die
schwedinnen die olympischen sommerspiele
2000 32 finden in brisbane stadt und
damit zum dritten mal in australien
diese wahl trafen die mitglieder des
internationalen olympischen komitees
heute bei ihrer vollversammlung in tokio
50 jahre liegt der letzte titelgewinn
der milwaukee bucks zurück jetzt sind
sie zum zweiten mal nordamerikanische
basketball meister nach dem vierten
erfolg in der finalserie gegen die
phoenix suns mit 115 98 überraschend ihr
super überragend er superstar jannis an
tito combo milwaukee nördlich von
chicago an der ostküste gelegene stadt
feiert ihre helden und es scheint als
wäre jeder der 600.000 einwohner dabei
gekommen um ihm zu huldigen jannis
anpumpen der mit 50 punkten auch dieses
spiel man fast allein entschied unter
dem eigenen korb wie unter dem
gegnerischen krieg früh nennen sie ihn
hingebungsvoll den 26 jährigen griechen
wertvollster spieler der finalrunde und
grünen diesem spiel
ich vertraue dem team ich wollte es hier
in dieser stadt vollbringen mit diesen
fans ich bin einfach nur happy dass wir
es geschafft haben
50 jahre hatten sie warten müssen auf
diesen titel in der basketball provinz
milwaukee jetzt ist es vollbracht das
wassersport und der name ist eine
gewisse herausforderung kann man nicht
anders sagen aber toller typ
doch das lotto die gewinnzahlen lauten
78 18 38 39 48 und die superzahl 2
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
bis freitag bleibt schön ab samstag
drohen gewitter von westen wie
gefährlich die werden erklärt gleich
katja horneffer 14 meldet sich christian
sieh was mit dem heute-journal und wir
sind morgen wieder taten sie mir danke
für ihr interesse einen schönen abend
noch und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend über dem atlantik braucht
sich schon das wochenendwetter zusammen
das ist ein tief das bringt uns zunächst
sehr warme luft und dann wird diese luft
immer feuchter und dann drohen ab
samstagnachmittag auch wieder kräftige
gewitter unwetter die mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen verbunden sind
davon merken wir in dieser nacht noch
nichts da gibt's höchstens in
norddeutschland dichtere wolkenfelder
sonst ist es häufig klar
die temperaturen sinken auf 15 grad
besonders an der küste und bis auf 9
grad in den östlichen mittelgebirgen an
der küste wird es morgen kaum wärmer da
erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen zwischen
19 und 21 grad sonst sind es in
norddeutschland 20 bis 24 südlich von
mosel und main etwa 25 bis 28 grad am
wetter ändert sich wenig auch morgen
geht es wieder viele wolken in
norddeutschland aber die sonne kommt
nachmittags immer häufiger zum zuge und
es kann hier und da auch mal für einen
kleinen regenschauer erreichen in
süddeutschland da geht es morgen viel
sonnenschein aber am nachmittag könnte
es dann über der schwäbischen alb oder
auch im schwarzwald mal für einen
kleinen schauer erreichen an diesem
wetter wird sich auch am freitag nichts
ändern aber am samstag da kommen dann
die gewinner an mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen sind ich verbunden und werden
am sonntag dann weiter richtung norden
und osten ziehen
guten abend